[Music]
when I first got started in web
development cloud storage buckets were a
relatively new technology and getting
user generated files uploaded to the
cloud was a major pain point but luckily
today we have firebase which makes this
process much easier but just as flexible
for the developer in today's video
you'll learn how to build a drop zone
style file uploader in angular that can
handle multiple concurrent files to
firebase storage if you're new here like
and subscribe and grab the full source
code from fire ship IO I created a
similar video about a year ago but the
number one request has been a system
that handles multiple files concurrently
so in this demo you can drop as many
files as you want onto the drop zone and
then you can pause or cancel each
individual upload the cool thing is that
firebase will handle all the concurrency
under the hood so you can have your
users drop as many files as you want
here and firebase will choose the best
strategy to get those files uploaded to
the cloud which is based mostly on the
user's network connection and another
thing we'll do is save the download URL
to this file in fire store this makes it
really easy to access the raw file if
you're already using fire store in other
parts of your application now I'm going
to show you how to build the drop zone
from scratch and angular but one thing
you should check out is this custom file
drop element from google chrome labs it
has nothing to do with angular
but because web components are awesome
you can just drop it into your angular
app and start using it so this might be
a good alternative for building your own
custom drop zone let's go ahead and get
started first I'm assuming that you have
an angular app along with angular fire
and firebase installed if we take a look
at the app module you can see I have
angular fire storage and fire store and
if we take a look at the CSS for this
application we have a drop zone class
which is just a flexbox with a border
then we have a hovering class that will
change the border from dash to solid
when the user hovers over the box and
all the other styles come from a
framework called bulma which if you're
not familiar with is a cool alternative
to bootstrap or material the first thing
we'll do is generate a directive that
will be able to turn any div into a drop
zone and by drop zone I just mean an
area that the user can drag and drop
files to and then we can receive those
files as an event in our web application
so we'll go ahead and call that
directive drop zone and it's
responsibility is to receive the files
and then you mitt them up as a custom
event that we can listen to and other
components in angular we create custom
events by using a combination of output
and event
Mitter this allows a parent component to
listen to events that happen in this
child directive in this case here we're
creating a custom event called dropped
that emits a file list and a file list
is built into the browser and it
contains the actual files that the user
dragged on to this element then we'll
also emit a custom event called hovered
that will tell us whether or not the
user is hovering over the element so we
can toggle that border from here we're
going to use host listener to intercept
the drop event in the Dom drop will
happen after the user drags they setup
files over to the drop zone and then
let's go on the mouse normally this
would cause a new browser tab to open so
we call event prevent default to stop
that from happening from there we want
the directive to emit the files out as a
custom event and we can access the files
by calling event data transfer files and
we'll also go ahead and emit falls
through our hovered event so that takes
care of the file drop event we also want
to listen to drag over and drag leave
any met true or false depending on
whether or not the user is dragging over
the element and that takes care of the
entire directive you now have a way to
compose this logic into any component or
element in your angular app now we can
move on to the actual file uploading
logic because we want to handle multiple
concurrent file uploads we'll have a
parent that manages all of the files
that the user dropped and then each
child component will manage the actual
upload of that file you can see here
I've generated two new components one is
the uploader that's the parent and then
one is the upload task that's the child
let's start with the logic for the
parent component it's going to have a
property is hovering which we can just
use to toggle the border on the drop
zone and it also has an array of files
first we'll define this toggle hover
event handler which will just flip that
property from true to false then the on
drop event handler takes the file list
as its argument the file list contains
all of the files but it's not something
that we can just loop over directly with
a for each loop so instead we have to
set up a traditional for loop here and
then we'll add it to the array of files
on this component the reason we do this
is so we can pass each individual file
to a child component in the angular
template now we can go into the template
and we'll set up a div here with our
drop zone class and then we'll add that
drop zone directive that we created
earlier this gives us access to the
custom events that we created like
Hubbard and on drop an angular has a
built-in class directive that we can use
to toggle the hovering class whenever
the is hovering property is
true we could stop there and the
drag-and-drop feature would work
perfectly fine but it's also a good idea
to add a file input field so users on
mobile devices can just click a button
to upload or for those on desktop that
just don't want to drag-and-drop we can
use the same on drop event handler but
for the argument we want to pass the
event target files and the event itself
is the change event on that format but
the last thing we need to do here is
loop over the array of files each file
will be passed as an input property to
the child upload task component now it's
time to move on to the upload task and
that's where we'll write the code that
actually uploads the file to cloud
storage
we'll start by importing our angularfire
dependencies and a few things from rxjs
and in this demo we're going to have the
upload start as soon as the component is
initialized but you could easily modify
this to make it more lazy if you want
the user to push a button first before
it actually uploads the file first we
decorate the file property with input so
it can be passed down from the parent
component and we have the angularfire
upload task which does most of the magic
for the file upload itself then while
the file is uploading it provides a
couple of different observables that we
can listen to to monitor the progress
percentage and snapshot will help us do
that and will also display the download
URL for the file when the upload is
complete from there we'll add our
dependencies to the constructor which
are angularfire storage and DB for
firestore and we'll define the upload
logic and its own method and then run
that method as soon as the components
initialized and again you could extract
that out to a button if you want to make
it a lazy upload the first step is to
define the path in the storage bucket
where this file will be saved
I am also adding a timestamp to the file
name just to ensure that it's unique you
don't have to do this but keep in mind
that file names need to be unique so if
you upload a file to the same location
with the same name the latest one will
override the old one from there I'll use
storage to make a reference to that
actual location in the bucket then
calling upload will start the actual
file upload to firebase storage it's not
an observable there's no need to
subscribe to it but it does provide
observables that we can use to monitor
the progress of the upload percentage
changes is just a number ranging from 0
to 100 that makes it easy to create a
progress bar then snapshot changes is an
observable that emits an object every
few hundred milliseconds with a bunch of
data about the file upload it contains
the bytes transferred as
a bunch of other information so I
recommend you console.log it so you can
take a closer look then rxjs has a
finalized operator that runs after this
observable is completed I've
experimented with a few different
approaches here but I think what makes
the most sense is just to add an async
function that gets the download URL and
converts it to a promise the reason I
like this approach is because we first
need this download URL before we can run
our update to the firestore database and
with async await we can just do this in
two lines of code we first get the
download URL and then we make a
reference to the files collection and
add that document to the database
as a final touch I'm adding this is
active method which will tell us whether
or not an upload is currently running
this just makes it easier to disable the
cancel and pause buttons based on the
state of the upload now at this point we
just need to unwrap our observables in
the template I like to unwrap the
observables inside of ng-if and then set
the value as a template variable this
allows us to use this percent variable
just like a synchronous value in the
template we can set this as the value to
our progress bar and then also display
the raw value as well we can unwrap the
snapshot in the same way
that'll give us access to the bytes
transferred which we can then compare to
the total bytes of the file and then we
can also display our download URL in
here as well but the coolest part is
that the angularfire upload task allows
us to control the upload itself for
example if we want the user to be able
to control the upload we can add a pause
button here and then just call task
pause to pause it then we can do the
same thing for cancel and resume and
lastly we'll use that is active method
that we defined earlier to just disable
these buttons depending on the current
state of the upload if we go back to the
demo and start uploading some files we
should get results that look like this
each individual file will have its own
progress indicator and if we click pause
a resume it should react accordingly and
if we pull up the firestore database you
should also see the download URL B and
save there as well hopefully that gives
you a good starting point for your own
file uploading system if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
make sure to grab the full source code
from fire ship IO thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]